[Music]
crimes have played a big role in many
famous movies and TV shows and of course
when there's a crime there's also going
to be punishment and this usually means
someone is going to prison
when filmmakers need to shoot a prison
scene instead of recreating one from
scratch in a studio they can now film
everything at the Arthur Kill
Correctional Facility in New York which
has been converted into a fully
functional production facility we got an
inside look at how they turned what was
once a prison into a go-to set for movie
and TV production hey guys we are here
at the Arthur Kill Correctional Facility
on Staten Island this is where shows and
movies like orange is the new black
daredevil and oceans 8 film their prison
scenes let's go inside and take a look
but first a little history the former
Binns prison opened in 1976 and could
hold 931 prisoners Arthur Kill is the
strip of water between Staten Island and
New Jersey which is how it got its name
Governor Andrew Cuomo closed the prison
in 2011 after which Broadway stages
purchased the property leaving much of
it intact one of the most famous areas
to shoot is the front of the visitors
entrance with its iconic guard tower
where you can get a good view of the
grounds over watching the prison this is
where Sandra Bullock walks out in the
beginning of oceans 8
[Music]
and where we see the inmates leaving at
the end of season six of Laurens of the
new black
[Applause]
all right so we're standing here in the
visitors area of the prison this is we
come in you get signed in you get
checked get processed through and then
they would lead you through to meet up
with your prisoner all right here you go
here's my stuff let's go let's go make a
movie surrounding the facility is the
same barbed wire fencing from the prison
to make it look authentic also authentic
the giant keys that are still used to
lock up various parts of the building
this is why you want this is the key to
the shoe these things are heavy-duty
next on the tour it was the visitation
room where many crime dramas are
typically set Arthur Kill has an area
where you could meet at a table or
behind a thick pane of glass and quote
the great George Bluth I may have
committed minor treason when we visited
we noticed several prop vending machines
left around the room so like as you can
tell this was a prop because everything
has turned backwards cuz I can't show
the logos that being said it looks like
there's a big raid on the snacks and
whatever scene they were filming here
because it is slim pickins but the
pickings were even slimmer in the
kitchen orange is the new black filmed
season seven at Arthur Kill and they
left behind plenty of fake prop food
they say prison food is really bad buy
bet prop prison food is even worse
because it's not real foam taters
connecting much of the prison is an area
called Broadway it's as big like
imposing hallway where sets are built
they're like moves from one wing to
another and when this was a prison this
was like the main stretch that connected
it all together what was once the prison
gym has now been converted into a huge
soundstage which we couldn't film
because Hulu's whoo tang and American
saga was in production inside there's
also a chapel classrooms and a
greenhouse while on tour we noticed a
really heavy-duty looking iron door
which turned out to be a total fake let
me out here easy but this door an area
of the prison might look familiar
since it was part of a huge escape seen
in Netflix's daredevil
which of course we had to try and
reenact kiki sound a daredevil fight
scene was also filmed in the prison's
Medical Center we didn't get to see the
general population cells but for oranges
the new black much of those scenes are
filmed at their set at Astoria Coffman
Studios in Queens
the infamous shoe scene however was
filmed at the prison facing my fears
going to the shoe each cell was
outfitted with beds a small sink and a
toilet I could see why like this is like
ideal to make a show or a movie because
like you were really immersing yourself
in that environment while many TV shows
and movies come here for the prison
aesthetic the grounds are also used for
other types of productions as well the
space behind us this big open parking
lot was used to look like Afghanistan on
CBS's the code in the swimming pool has
been converted into a different type of
soundstage one which can be used to film
underwater scenes filming at a place
like Arthur Kill instead of a studio can
make a show or film seem all the more
real without breaking the bank just
don't forget the keys when you're
putting your actors behind bars I would
like a piece of cake but preferably if
the cake had like a key baked into it or
maybe some kind of way then get me out
of here for the purpose of the scene I'm
in thank you